nouveaux débats au tribunal
administratif autour de l'éventuel
déficit de plus de 23 millions d'euros
une déclaration des membres de la ctm
qui avait fait l'objet de nombreuses
discussions dans l'hémicycle à plateau
roy elle avait aussi nécessité
l'intervention de la chambre régionale
des comptes et de didier migaud premier
président de la cour des comptes ce
matin
màj sera analysé une requête introduite
par les membres de son pool martin
nouvelle est clairement l'annulation
d'une délibération du budget 2010 est de
la 7ème après analyse des conclusions
des moyens et des arguments des deux
parties
le rapporteur public demande le rejet de
cette requête
je le rejoins dans la démarche même si
moi j'y ajoute d'autres éléments
le tigre et de la tardiveté
d'introduction de la requête présentée
par messieurs du verger à jaar et des
autres utilisant accompagner dans cette
entreprise
et puis le deuxième c'est sur la réalité
financière de la collectivité et il est
très clair que malgré cet avis de la crc
qui a été rendu à la demande du préfet
de région martinique au moment où la ctm
est installé il y à un déficit
budgétaire qui est celui qui a été voté
lors du compte administratif du vote du
compte administratif 2015 donc en 2016
l'avocat d' ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle à une autre lecture de cette
situation budgétaire lorsque
l'équipe de la fois d'origine arrive
aux affaires il décide de faire voter un
déficit de 23 millions d'euros et ce
déficit entraîne que le préfet est
obligé saisi la chambre régionale des
comptes qui après analyse se rend compte
qu'il n'ya pas de déficit de 23 millions
d'euros mais il ya plutôt un excédent de
535 millions trois cent trente cinq
mille euros ont par conséquent le préfet
devrait faire en sorte que ces éléments
là soit intégrée aux comptes
il n'a point fait le rapporteur public
ne dis pas que les élus ont eu tort au
contraire simplement ils disent vous
auriez dû le faire plus tôt ce dossier
très sensible est mise en délibéré à une
date ultérieure